Sadie and Lars sitting in a tree
na you ckin shaping weight that's what
you took out of it I thought they just
really took playing video games very
seriously I think it's a metaphor for
sex this is a good place a decent place
you will not bring that smut here sir
they were playing video games and that's
it and she I as most gamers get very
emotional when she's called in to be a
player - and you know he plays with fire
one but then doesn't let her have a turn
to get noticed and acknowledged so she's
number two huh just number two it's a
very abusive relationship they gotta go
now they're fucking Finkle I gotta say I
really like this episode but when we got
to that ending I'm like wait a shit this
isn't a happy ending what what did this
asshole her what dude
you know it's like I guess I want to
help it's like no no there are so many
more layers here I'm sorry it doesn't
just stop with oh I just want to help
clean up stuff like that people here
they did pretty much burn his esophagus
bullshit he's a dog like he's he
probably gonna die of perforated organs
as trying to bleed his whole body's
gonna go septic he's dead he literally
is a walking dead person so I think
maybe he will have learned his lessons
now you'll be a dead rotting six feet
under well his ghost okay
that's looked at it well maybe just
maybe I shouldn't treat her like shit
because the weird kid with the gem of
the stomach killed me you mean a fiery
poison do you know when I put it like
that this show seems weird
now I'll touch I'm just a touch weird um
no see you got this episode where uh
this team goes to the donut shop and
Lara sacks it fakes a back injury and
dick yeah and so pretty much she
promotes Steven just for a day to work
there
think exactly he's thinking like you
know we should just fire Lars which
actually seemed very mean-spirited for a
Steven but he's kind of rise that dope
very right and then you find out that
they have this reason if nothing gets
him but this been the best day of my
life so we should totally fire ours
that's just okay then it's like she
admits it's like no nose cuz we have
this past history which is like which I
like I would at first I was joking I was
like reading between the lines it was
like oh you went over two and then as
when oh the video games yes I'm like
okay they just went there yeah no way
said you know way cell was about fun
games what yeah game is like there's no
confusing that bedroom games play to
baby there's playthroughs press start a
TV that's all what she was just trying
to get you know the girl use hanging out
with to be player three maybe you know
good little sister oh fuck what it ends
up being a four player game it's gonna
get kind of complicated yeah yeah three
totally do before that's just it does
give new meaning to Super Smash Brothers
and melee one okay it's two girls that
be smash sisters as well yeah are super
smash it so they they put this fire salt
on is a Honda donut and he just starts
breathing fire great animation there was
some good slam this is some of the best
I'll even go beyond that the animation
not just with the opening with him right
to the soda and wearing it in point to
the ground I mean all that was great but
the animation on her when she's just
crying I mean it's like it was tugging
at the hearts really like looking back I
saw you didn't know bad uh and it's one
of those things where it's like I'm just
watching well and it's like just the
motions they ever go through it sort of
like the the different emotions and
certain at the hair and then the anger
and the sadness and the talking to a tee
baby it's like really fucking well
animated and then you also have the
great slapstick with him reading the
fire that is really good image it's like
Ren Stimpy animation yeah really really
funny so the animation this one even
though like technically there's no
monsters or anything like that I just
thought with top notch um
yeah so he eventually goes and sets
everything on fire and they stop it and
you know Joel Joel's plan to have the
world's largest bowl of ice cream what I
found out it melts a sigh why'd you
bring yourself at the meeting um I would
love it if there was dr. Forrester like
this was an invention exist if behold
I've created the world's largest ice
cream sundae what do you think I know we
know what happened like you know he left
the sale I love came to earth and you
know mayor of this town and he's just
all these we are put in function when
that came out this is now technically
the not-too-distant future so it kind of
was terrible um but yeah so I just don't
I know the idea is like hey this is like
a beginning of him being better or
something like that but that was by
fucking dick stuff not just faking the
injury and then trying to get another
day but that whole thing about the past
of what ladies really really dick stuff
ladies you know take that shit but don't
settle I I don't have to be player to I
just looked at that I mean at the very
ending and I'm just like no this is not
a happy ending and I don't think it was
meant to be you know sort of like this
kind of not happy ending I think it's
mostly I go they they both learn self
got here something like down guys you
shouldn't have to be player to either
just saying if there's some girl
treating you like that
you don't have to sort of man nobody has
to settle we should just share the
controller somebody can move I'll hit a
and B will be it's like the the power
pad for a Nintendo you know like
somebody you know - Wow
once I are gonna be Helena's just
sitting here staring at this what the
fuck is a Power Pad assistant it sounds
a lot it's an ting the Angry Video Game
Nerd uses a cape okay pretty much yeah
uh didn't we did something weird over we
oh we also worked on something where we
all sir I hit the pad with pants or when
we were supposed to be running the thing
was designed to get us to exercise but
if you just bang your hands I guess
something else
no I'm are we tried to do we thought
like if we did the back buttons as well
like that somehow made it go faster by
can't remember it actually did but were
you really off topic here so no no
player one no player two just power that
don't settle yes somebody is abusing you
just don't put up with that shit what
you should settle it's like you leave a
purpose hey I'm and it's like super
muscle build and stuff like if you're
looking for really unreasonable
expectations yes that done subtle at
that point so um but if you're being
legitimately abused or shit upon by
somebody who is literally calling you
number two don't set I guess like you
know I felt like what they do with
Harley Quinn and the Joker and the
Batman cartoon and how they made it
clearly an abusive relationship and that
was the tragedy she would keep falling
for it and keep coming back and you keep
manipulating her but they were obviously
showing this is a bad thing we're here
it's like I don't know if I was watching
this as a kid or something like that do
you know I wouldn't know what to make an
a tenday I wouldn't be like we don't
know where you don't know where they're
going with I guess I mean there's many
more episodes left so I guess but until
we get to an episode where we see where
that relationship went it's like this is
not a good place to leave off I don't
know you know it's getting heavy
boom sindbad sindbad is it man whatever
in this uh I got some I it was funny I
had somebody posting on my public
Facebook just like know you guys don't
like thin band I'll have you know he's
mr. smiley and you liked him so suck on
that and I'm like okay you ruin my life
ie matter fit I had this beautiful world
of perfection until you brought that up
and just crumbled it the world was all
based on hating sin bed and now I am
just trying I think it's generally
saying most of sin bad stuff I don't
find that amusing I take a stand up
isn't that bad but uh this stand-ups
alright but i think is that's not to say
I don't think he can't be funny oh she's
a very nice guy I mean
it aery Adam Sandler films I like it say
what films I love yeah so it's just like
I I don't think I've met a comedian yet
where it hasn't been funny once well
maybe carrot ah but in the Sun sometimes
Ryan I think it's something funny carrot
top it's but Holly show her maybe that'd
be one that's like I I actually liked
Encino man and he was mostly harmless in
that Tracy Morgan is are for me that's a
I'm tried to pay him ever reliant to
Tracy Morgan huh dude and I I'm sure
he's a very nice man everyone says he's
soubrette wonderful continue being a
nice man do you make a living that way
Ben Fanta if you found a finger Tracy
Morgan I just Ellison all hate mail to
Doug Walker gabber channel awesome if
you find them funny great you know I'm
he's doing nothing wrong either but yeah
I mean most comedians out there even if
I'm not a fan of their style or cuz
comedies really subjective oh it's like
yeah how dare you know like I'm like
like there's comedians and most people
agree and they're generally good that I
don't like there's some comedians
everybody hates that I kind of like yeah
uh sighs you I'm Dean cook but I don't
mind although he was not very good in
this movie this is five no no but I like
that - I enjoyed his stand-up said hey
you know it's subjective so just because
we're just like oh yeah we're not huge
Sinbad fans doesn't mean he can't show
up on a show like this ya know what are
you gonna do be like no we hate Sinbad
now ya know if somebody's going some
people will say you're good that's fine
so Sinbad
you were funny good job you're you're
good don't grab her you know uh I never
worked a fast-food job or any kind of
customer service job or anything like
that so I did know these videos I knew
they had videos introduced by I did know
so remember we're having his tail yeah I
never knew these rats in these musical
bits were like so confident like that
was a Gamestop the one that no
overviewed well no no no Ellen what what
was that one of those videos or whether
the one thing was the Wendy's one I mean
when I saw it I'm like this is amazing
so cold I thought your satirizing vapid
I had to remember
oh yeah there's like there was a lot of
these where they have like this songs
raps and stuff like that uh so yeah I
felt was a pretty funny it kind of sent
up to see I'm not wondering if they saw
that what see what I've attained I'm
wondering like because we were like how
can they do something so awful I kind of
think it's like the Mentos commercials I
think it was in tell yeah yeah I think
that yeah why you to remember it yeah
how you to remember lunch and remember
it so it's like we will make this as
cheesy and as ridiculous as possible so
you will never forget this in your
entire life or any old Navy and gap
commercials those were dog shit but we
all remember them we remember them doing
like West Side Story or that dog we got
poppin hands assembly dog did take a
shit probably um no yeah it was a good
episode with I ah I don't like that
ending personally but um I go with I
like I like the right I don't can't I
can't I don't have an opinion one way or
another because we don't know where it's
going yeah a lot of these end on a
strange note and you just accept it and
move it so I I know I think because I
know it's trying to feel comfortable
ending you know in lace it could go
somewhere else it probably will go
somewhere else - because they're showing
it's a comfortable ending I think the
idea was for it to be instructive in
that he should change and he says let me
help in this mad it's aimed at kids the
reality is a lot of people like that
don't change so but you know they do
that is such a massive thing that
message several things that he did and
when you bring in video games into the
equation - there's this mezzo mal
responsibility that I still didn't feel
was being tackled from him or show they
was gonna start being tackle it's just
like oh I'll help you clean up and I
know it's like whatever metaphor is to
stuff but it's like I just didn't feel
that was enough for this for the pain
that they show her going through and for
the big dip that they show him not in
that way but in the other way uh you
know the play or - way it is not to me
it's not a satisfying enough I don't
know maybe maybe at the end of Jesus
there's three seasons to the show well
maybe after the whole show is
/ okay I got see the plan okay yeah
you'll even be I see the plan or I'll
look back on this episode me like you're
right but I now I don't like the ending
but who knows they could be going
somewhere else with this so a good stuff
I get great animation on it uh a good
voice acting too from and I love that em
pictures amethyst just like we make a
good team you can't do anything no
actually the one thing I was missing it
shall live me the one thing I'll service
with the star comes in she's chewing I
do wire to say thing just food like
nothing that's why I felt what been a
little funnier but that's rewrite
thinking uh but you know I said you're
right I took a bit no you said he don't
take backs easy see you the next one I'm
right huh
you'll be wrong again you're right
damn it I said you're right who's rose
again